to me this is the most interesting thing
in all of the internet right and the
reason being a couple years ago I
started thinking pretty deeply about
this idea of like audience is the new
currency and I think a lot of people use
that as like Oh some advertisers are
gonna come pay me money and then I can
simply you know post or do whatever and
I get that cash but what you're talking
about there's a very well-known author
who one time said to me if somebody's
willing to pay me to reach my audience
that means that that audience is more
valuable to me than it is to them right
basically I can sell my own things
through all this kind of stuff and they
started to walk me through like look
looking for very specific types of
products that were high margin that he
could sell through that he knew that
there was a wide enough kind of interest
in this audience like he was very very
smart about it and it sounds like you
guys are thinking through a lot of that
same stuff has it been driven at all or
do you see coral corollary kind of
analysis to what
whether it's Kylie Jenner Kanye West
like a number of these people have done
where they already had built-in
audiences and then they went and created
a product it feels like that's a much
more repeatable sustainable business
model given that you retain ownership of
that audience right so you can build
multiple products and multiple companies
and keep kind of bringing them more and
more things over time rather than just
an advertiser comes one time you
advertise once it then they're gone like
the company piece seems more sustainable
and repeatable right of course of course
yeah you control it I mean especially in
the influencer and content creator
business is advertisers are afraid
they're afraid you know and and their
expectations are so high because people
are comparing YouTube to television
they're saying okay well you know you
spend this much money on that TV show
that had two million views well I'm
getting 10 million views you know so I'm
five times more and you know and and you
know there's always that tug-of-war
between the creator and the advertiser
and then advertiser eventually says okay
someone at the office says that you know
when you might be right let's give it a
shot and then the conversion is not the
same because people on the internet just
don't want to see ads they don't have to
see ads on television you know you're
you're kind of stuck you're forced you
know unless you know you previously
recorded and you fast forward to it
but you know or if you're it's a radio
you know station like you know you're
kind of a force unless you just switch
the station but on the internet business
is just like you know the conversion is
so much lower that's you know then the
advertiser says that that person was
wrong oh by the way look at this guy
he's now swearing in his content or he's
smoking weed or he did this or she did
that and and then you know didn't then
someone says hey why did you do that
that wasn't children-friendly you know
and then all this whole mess comes in
and the advertiser pulls out and we
never hear from them again
so and and I don't blame the advertiser
right it is the wild wild west on the
internet right now people are just you
know I mean the more yourself the better
your content your better your channel is
going to grow but the more yourself the
more you know you're less political your
lest phony so you know it's not what the
apertures are advertisers want to see
they want to see the picture-perfect
version of you so so an advert I said
okay this is not for us so then where
does that leave you know when you went
back bragging about getting ten million
views how are you going to now make
money you know you're just gonna brag
about the ten million views and live at
home or live on your buddy's couch you
know so that's that's when you know then
you got to go and you got to create your
own t-shirt and create a culture and a
following and not a following to number
following somebody that really cares
about you and Bill and and have them
join this culture how them joined is
click or squad whatever you want to call
it and buy a product and now that money
goes directly to you
you know Shopify since daily deposits
yeah I mean so you're literally making
money every single day when you wake up
much data goes into determining what
plot for companies to build versus it's
like the creators intuition and just
personal interest I think so you know
it's like creating a video you know
you're gonna sometimes the were even
guilty of this will create a video that
we just wanted to do and it just doesn't
register with the audience and we'll
just keep doing it and doing it and
doing it it's something that we're
passionate about
and then the audience like and then you
see the views and engagement go up I
think a products a product that a
creator really wants to get behind it's
just kind of going to have to be the
same thing you know you could take
advice from people you could you know
right like right now CIA has CIA labs
where like they really take I haven't
used it but I've heard about it and I
know the people behind it they're very
smart people so you know they're they're
going in and they're you know they're
looking at like your audience on across
everywhere you are on the internet and
pitching creators like we think your
audience is gonna like you know George
pickles and you know and you know
seltzer water you know whatever it is
you know like you know III think that
could work but at the end of the day it
really depends on what the audience
wants you know if you're a comedian with
the very low fall you're a comedian with
a very young following then maybe you
know custom suits is not your thing you
know so you just have to kind of really
understand your audience no different
than when you're making the video you're
making the music is what does your
audience one and the product has to be
the same thing as shots right now we're
trying trying to treat products like a
creator you know and we want to turn
products into creators and that's why
you know I mean I'm a big fan of this
liquid death you know I mean like this
is content it is you know people laughed
they you know they you know they asked
questions I had a call with their team
last week about content ideas and you
know it's like this is this is content
this draws your attention you know is
like what is that you want to know more
I've read everything on this can all the
labels everything just to get a kick out
of it and you know it's all standard
stuff that they have legals of the New
York put but even like the fonts I'm
looking at it you know I mean it's just
like got my attention and that's turning
a product into a content creator and and
if a creator could get behind one of
these and do that with the product and
you have these two things is just stab
it's more explosive and you see a lot of
youtubers do that with merch right now
the best merch that sells right now is
March built around their content and
their fandoms versus like a picture of
their face with their name on it
you know those don't really convert well
people don't really want to buy your
name on a t-shirt they want to buy
something cool that fun that you made
that it says that has been incorporated
into your content so then they're part
of the following a part of the squad
they're part of the you know the the
audience that you building yeah and how
much of this is now being empowered by
the stripes of the world the Shopify's
you know all of these kind of
infrastructure companies that have made
it dead simple for creators to actually
do this themselves or is it even if
those companies didn't exist this was
already a trend that kind of people were
moving towards because you saw it
happening where people weren't using
Shopify stripe and things like that yeah
I don't think any of this is easily said
to do if there was no Shopify you know
it's not you know it wouldn't be
something I was like just get up and do
it you know because when you right now
when I tell you you and you and you know
your audience and whoever is listening
or even our creators is you don't have
to worry about how to do this you just
have to do worry about what to do and
what to sell you don't worry about how
how does the Shopify has made it so damn
easy that it's not even like like when
we launched the little shop calm which
is our merge site like Shopify and
building properly Shopify was like
action item number eight on our like 20
thing to do list you know it wasn't a
before used to be like I build a web
site figure this out and have analytics
and you know figure out emails and all
this but now it's like all right you
just it's like saying create an
Instagram account for the brand it's
just like that's not an important thing
more important thing is what to sell
right now the quality of it you know
right now that's the the top three
priorities to us with little shop and
any of our consumer goods products is
you know build something that the
audience loves make sure it's of quality
and have great customer service like
like Zappos love
customer service yeah I mean so the
person comes back you know you did all
this work to get them to go to the
website and purchase and put in a credit
card and you want them to come back and
those things ever what's makes it
important and Shopify has made it a
world where creators could we'll focus
on those three things and not worry
about how do I build a website who do I
call who I outsourced overseas you know
I mean like I mean you know if the word
I spent $50,000 on this thing either you
don't they worry about that you know
because that's what his website would
cost at the level Shopify when you're
talking about all the back and stuff
that they provide all the analytics
everything you know I mean like it's not
just a front-end thing that's the
backend thing that makes it Shopify what
it is